What was the last thing you tried to say to me at the campsite
? Yes, I
remembered it, but I wonder if it was a very important story. When I
see something like that, I feel relieved or
frustrated, but I
have mixed feelings about
life.  There was a time when I kept trying for a long time, but it seems like
my role was over halfway through the journey. I
think I only had a little time left, but I regret it. But I gave it my
all, and it still didn't come true,
so I don't regret it.  I'll give you this.
No, no, no, Tokiko, this is just a
stone. It's just a stone with no magical power. But it took a
person over 1,000 years to pick up that one stone. It
took over 1,000 years to pick up that one stone.  Then it seemed
like it was just Ishikawa. That's what I said, Masa-kun. Please
make that person happy. At
that time, I didn't know what that meant,
but it
was more important than the moonstone that was handed to me.  I feel like I've been entrusted with something.
[Music]
Yes,
leave it to me. I'll definitely
make Tsukasa-chan happy.
[Music]
When the weight is lifted off my shoulders, I feel better.
Then let's go back to this place.
What do you mean, this is good timing for you? This game is
really difficult, but what's going on? Even though I don't
like games at all, I'm still bad at it.
Don't play games like that all the time. It's nice weather,
so we're
a couple.  Let's have a nice talk, I
guess you're the
one who told me to do it.What were you two talking about secretly in a place like this?It was a
secret,
no, it wasn't that kind of a secret, so why don't you say something
weird to your husband again?  Well, if you
really want to know what people are talking about, you
should take a look at Nasu-kun.What is that?
[Music]